après plus de six mois de crise les
soignants sont fatigués ils l'ont dit
une nouvelle fois dans la rue
aujourd'hui
ils réclament des postes des ouvertures
de lits et de meilleurs salaires
hélène chapelet les blouses blanches ont
le blues ce jeudi après midi le
personnel soignant s'est donné rendez
vous place jean jaurès à tours pour
dénoncer une fois de plus le manque de
moyens et de reconnaissance de leur
profession et les personnels sont à bout
une situation qui ne date pas d'hier
avant même l'apparition de la crise
sanitaire le nombre de départs au chru
de tours alerte est déjà les syndicats
en 2019 par exemple il faut savoir qu'il
ya plus d'une centaine de départs toutes
catégories confondues au niveau du
personnel paramédical c'est près de 60
des missions ou des parents mise en
disponibilité c'est à dire que les
agents quittent l'hôpital pour faire
autre chose il ya un manque de moyens
qui est énorme et on le voit dans tous
les services moi qui suis peintre en
bâtiment de base et passe en la
maintenant ce bâtiment g malheureusement
pour pour l'hôpital fais le choix de
m'en aller de m'en aller ailleurs dans
un autre ministère pour pour avoir moi
de mon côté un salaire décent et surtout
une carrière professionnelle qui soit
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus intéressante
et soignants sans user dans un service
en ce moment à trousseau il ya six
agents qui sont en arrêt maladie dans le
même service
donc évidemment bas ça tourne pas donc
on ferme des lits et c'est inadmissible
aujourd'hui on voudrait que l'on soit
tous à temps plein
qu'on travaille que notre travail soit
reconnu et une revalorisation des
salaires
au même moment le premier ministre jean
castex promettait donc une deuxième
revalorisation des salaires pour le
personnel hospitalier de 93 euros nets
avant la fin de l'année cela
suffira-t-il à remonter le moral des
troupes passées sur le mal-être semble
profond et le coronavirus l'a de nouveau
mises au jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]